i have always been attracted to
visionaries
comedians and people who make me laugh
i was so attracted to our next guest i
even married him
yeah because that's what you do
please welcome a wonderful wonderful man
tom green
hi drew hi everybody
[Applause]
i brought charlie with me hello drew how
are you i'm nice to see you
i'm so good i know you have a new woman
in your life
yes this is my uh my new puppy uh
charlie and
we're taking off on a van trip and we're
gonna travel around the country together
and uh i'm really looking forward to it
but great to see you
and congratulations on your incredible
show
i'm so happy to be here and was so happy
when you invited me on the show
thank you so much this is amazing i am a
little back story for
anyone um is that we we haven't
seen or spoken to each other in far too
long thanks for having me here drew and
i'm really really
couldn't be more excited about your new
show it's nice to see you every day on
here just bringing this burst of
happiness and
energy and optimism to the world right
now
thank you dick and mary jane my mother
and father they say hello by the way and
they're really happy that i'm here on
the show and they're
they're happy for you and uh we're all
really happy for you actually we uh
we love watching you uh do amazing
things and we're so excited about your
new show
i've had two nights of great sleep in my
life um
before my daughters were born and i
don't know why but sleep is like
it's just been like a weird thing for me
and
i remember this night just being so
content and i was at your parents lake
house
and i remember hearing all their voices
upstairs and i was just by
myself and i was going to sleep and i
was like yeah this is what
you know safety and contentedness feels
before you're going to sleep
and i will never forget that night and i
love your parents
and i really love you and i celebrate
you and you know when you say like
20 years it's sometimes it's the blink
of an eye
and sometimes you're like oh my god
we've lived so much in these last 20
years
you've had a whole life and i've had a
whole life
and it's just really nice to come
together
and check in and talk about it it just
it thrills me to no end and i think the
world of you
and i celebrate you and i always have
and i always will
thank you thank you this is uh really
i was so happy when you invited me on
the show it's been it's been too long we
should have
you know it's nice to reconnect we
really did not talk for about 15 years
i guess and this is really the first
time we've
looked at each other face to face in 15
years and you know
one of the things that means so much to
me professionally also is because
one of the reasons that you know we got
to know each other in the first place
was
i admired your work so much and so i
reached out to you and you know asked
you
to come and do charlie's angels and you
so graciously said yes
i just i that was so exciting getting to
do that movie with
with you and uh you know we kind of uh
sort of hit it off right away pretty
much yeah we had a lot of laughs
together
i think one of our first dates uh i
think we went and
bought uh lobsters because we both love
animals yeah
and we both uh got lobsters yeah and we
we went
we released them into the uh into the
into the ocean
yeah that was what we decided to do we
did and you
bought me a camera um and i still have
it the pentax k-1000
and you got me started into what would
become
you know two decades full of being a
real
photographer and you got me into my
whole annie hall
phase of you know taking
photographs which is such a beautiful
art and it
it tracks me back to what you were doing
when you did it there was no
technology available there was no
internet there was like
no cell phones there was no
social media and you opened the
floodgates of all of it
and you did it in this way where you
really
messed with people but it wasn't mean
and it wasn't angry and when you can go
that far
and push the envelope to that degree
what you say about not being mean that
that was always part of it i would never
want to do something to someone that was
actually mean but if i went out and did
something really stupid
and they got me mad at me that was that
was the the humor in it for me so
i mean did you start with a camcorder i
like tech you know i'm a geek right
yeah i like technology i like technology
and i like uh cameras and computers
and and editing and and i'm always
playing with
the latest technology so sometimes when
you see what the new camera is or the
new microphone or the new
editing machine that's coming out you
try to think how you're going to do
something creative with that and then we
just went out and made this crazy show
when we were in our early 20s and
and just were wild and ridiculous
and had a great time and i remember i
remember when mtv
picked up the show and moved me down to
new york city how exciting it was
and i remember you called over to the
studio and that was
very cool very exciting and then
i eventually when i moved to los angeles
i met you and we did charlie's angels
and now
travels with charlie maybe maybe it
makes sense that the chad would have a
dog named charlie right
i'm the chad yes
it might be the chat good morning
starfish
good morning the chad
you